hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich sitze ja
alleine auf der seite der welt die welt
ist eine zeitschrift und sie hat das
wundervolle quiz weißt du was diesem
modus wirklich bedeuten rausgehauen von
charlotte simmons what's up
das klingt mir gar unnötig aber ich habe
auf den test geklickt und es ist
tatsächlich schwierig nennen wenn wir
nämlich zuallererst ein quiz frage gehen
sehen wir diesen kollegen hier und da
steht starten wir mit etwas einfachen
was symbolisiert dieses mal wenn ich
ganz ehrlich bin ich weiß es nicht ich
will ja da ist also ich mach den smiley
immer wenn so okay so wenn sowieso ist
mir egal oder nicht mal böse gemeint
also ich würde sagen ich glaube der
umarmt ehrlich gesagt ja was würdest du
sagen also ich glaube ich weiß wie das
bei dem motto hier die anderen sachen
sind unnötig aber ohne die
antwortmöglichkeiten 100 jahre und
möglichkeiten ist es echt schwer das so
schwer zu sagen was man sagen wir nichts
machen fröhlich ist ja auch nicht auf
jeden fall auch aber ich würde auch
sagen ihrem abend tatsächlich um einen
armen so nummer zwei was tut dieses in
mode gerade damit leute sagen das gemüt
der immer mehr in die pflicht es ist
enttäuscht es ist krank
es ist traurig dass mit der wasser hand
ist wirklich super wiederholt und war
steht das ist schade
okay lasst uns anfangen wird seien krank
aber so richtig korrigiert das
ausbildungs voneinander ist ja was soll
also was eine nase raus und er hat keine
land ich würde fast sagen es ist
enttäuscht also krank auch aber es gibt
ja ein extra symbole ja mit dem
thermometer dann kommen wir sagen
enttäuscht meist schläft ja
und ich nach rio ist vielleicht möchtest
du auf den augen so möchten besteht doch
so schreibt gleich in die kommentare
wenn ihr noch an seit ich sage es ist
ein tolles ich sage traurig es schlimm
war
nein viele von uns verwenden ist als
traurig sind jedoch einen dieses ein
schläfriger und jain kommt eine kleine
radfahrer aus der nase ist auch die
kleine rote fahne gesehen ich habe doch
gesagt die antwort ist schläft aber hat
schnupfen krass also hätte ich echt
nicht mitgerechnet dieses es wird
richtig sein neutrum gebrauch edv hoch
richtig das heißt tatsächlich das im
jobcenter bern hat recht gehabt
trotzdem dieses im auge ist nicht gut
drauf oder oder enttäuscht ich sag
enttäuscht enthält er aber gut es nichts
leichteres ein tolles bisschen
spezifischer yaez enttäuscht ja verwirrt
wer benutzt hast denn so wie du sagst
irgendwie kam com heute abend und drei
zum kaffee oder so schreibt also um drei
fragezeichen
sie verwaltet und immer jeder mensch
würde denken was ich je getan kraft also
anscheinend werde nämlich häufig nicht
in dem kontext verwendet indem sie
geschaffen wurden
und so viel steht dass wir stellen schon
mal einen klub schwindelgefühl wetten
schwindelgefühl meinte könnte seine die
machen den test obst drauflegen
schwindelgefühl tja
ja
hübsche lotte das parlament bestimmt
kennst du das zeichen noch aus alten
comics beispielsweise dass man genau
nachschauen beispiel bei 2 erfolg ist
wenn das kennt man aus cartoons
tatsächlich hatte sagte das ist das cool
energy nein ist es für ich bedauere
junge wenn das stimmt
kennst du das denn so wirklich heute in
diesen apotheken oder sonst irgendwas
das wort haben treffen
es ist wirklich kennt ich flirte auf das
mitmachen projektieren ja die idee hat
diese vorsicht falls du bzw
die bis dahin war schlecht der laune
ausdrücken wollen herr angewiesen
trauerfall in der familie oder so häufig
tut mir leid das level irgendwie
wirtschaft einem boarding wie es die
einfachste krankheit welchen satz würde
zu diesem emoticon zuweisen ich freue
mich wie ich bin aufgeregt alles ok oh
gott ist bestimmt irgendwie so ein
kulturelle sache ich würde aber sagen
alles ok sowie die schau aber in welcher
kultur macht man alles okay ich würde
eigentlich freue mich dass man den
sonnen die sonne ist eigentlich da sein
aber ich freue mich ist richtig alles
okay in japan ist gerissen worden
also ist wie habt ihr alle zu essen zu
trinken fragt wieso ein raum stadtteil
entstanden wollten einfach sagen so ja
ich habe hunger aufpreis
thorsten spilles chris aber größeren
haus in charleston also wirklich das
echte bis endlich cool finde ich gut was
siehst du hier eine erschöpfte katze
eine singende cup seine schreiende cups
eine erschrockene katze einer schraube
johanna entscheiden
eine katze hat keine angst aber die
richtige antwort ist eine schreiende
katze das ist ja auch das selber das ist
jetzt aber echt falsch weil richtig wäre
eine erschöpfte kannst du ja aber eine
debatte antworte mal was machst du wenn
du in video und herrschaftssystem heißt
nicht schwer wenn man schreit ein mann
schreit ja jeder kennt die box und
reihte er ist 18 und was soll hier zum
ausdruck gebracht werden erschöpfung
kopfschmerzen bei der verbeugung
verbeugung so aus zum ausdruck gebracht
habe ich auch noch ich sage einmal oder
doch ist vorbeugen aktiv mal wieder hoch
schaute aber ist sollte zum ausdruck
gebracht werden verbeugungen das doch
verwaltung ich habe verbeugung dann
würde man doch sagen man bringt keine
ahnung respekt zum ausdruck aber man
bringt nicht verbeugung zum ausdruck
ja ich sage verliebt ich sage viel
arbeiten
aber wie kann man das denn zum ausdruck
bringen man kann es machen dürft ihr
gefährt verbunden fühlt einfach man kann
noch mal machen wollen und was könnte es
diesmal seite kann ich aber dass ich das
macht einen satz gefüge können sind doch
hat man aber mit dem 7 so also wenn das
so groß ist erkannt dass es schon
vorbeugend würden ja dann ist man
einfach mit ärger ärger
das richtige symbol kommt aus animes und
mangas und soll die venen zum ausdruck
bringen einer wütenden person
hervortreten es steht also für ärger
welches adjektiv assoziiert du mit
diesem motiv aden froh verschmitzt
verbittert oder ambitioniert aber kein
schalter ambitioniert das verwenden
tatsächlich leute sowieso nach dem motto
weiter so kritisch man sich kennt halt
echt seien ambitioniert und so keine
ahnung
stell dir vor du hast den satz morgen
streichen wir meine wohnung dann endlich
und dann kommt so dieser immer wird
schon sinn machen außerdem benötigt den
benutzer niemand aber wenn ich mir
denken was geht es bei dem projekt
vielleicht ist es echt ambitioniert
dafür sagt er verschmitzt zusammen
die katze ist das pendant zum flirten
smiley wenn sich erschreckt hat schreibt
mike in die kommentare
worum handelt worum handelt es sich bei
dieser geste zeichen für liebe zeichen
für ablehnung geste der dankbarkeit
vulkanischer grus grus und zu guter
letzt dieses energy ist erschöpft
verzweifelt genervt oder gar 100
ich würde sagen erschöpft ich sah war
zweifelt eigentlich warte versorgung
ermöglichen ich sage verzweifelt
verschafft world in der mx2 fit du hast
mir gegeben ja ja das
na ja meistens versteht man was du sagen
möchtest und dann der pilot swinka ist
charlotte wenn du siehst danke für den
test das wars vom heutigen video es
gesorgt ist er selbst und auch in der
beschreibung
[Musik]